we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
in any time here's a voicemail that I
got over the weekend hello David I just
have a quick question so you're a fan of
national health care from what I assume
based off of your videos do you like the
skins Navis style of health care system
I do I may be wrong about that so my
question is if capitalism makes shoes
better in cars better in lawnmowers
better then why when it capitalism make
health care better yeah listen I've
talked about this before and I am a
believer in well regulated capitalism
like we see in many Scandinavian
countries and the reason why health care
is not made better by subjecting it to
open and free market sources is that the
demand for health care is hugely
inelastic it is not a market like shoes
and cars or whatever else it was that
the caller mentioned so I've talked
about this before you can find my videos
on this on YouTube and it's something
that we're actually going to be doing I
we have an interview lined up right
about when markets don't work or we're
working on it
that'll be tomorrow actually oh it's
tomorrow very good excellent so we will
be talking about that very very soon I
should know what I really should know
what the interview schedule is I'm gonna
make a note to and for myself but
fortunately Pat's informed yeah we're
going to talk about that more tomorrow
and I've been very very clear about why
the free market does not work in a in
education in health care and in some
other places great bonus show for you
today I'm out of time but trust me folks
it's a doozy